Our wine model had an R-squared value
of 0.83, which tells us how accurate our model
is
on the data we used to construct the model.
So we know our model does a good job predicting
the data it's seen.
But we also want a model that does well
on new data or data it's never seen before
so that we can use
the model to make predictions for later years.
Bordeaux
wine buyers
profit from being able to predict the quality
of a wine
years before it matures.
They know the values of the independent variables,
age
and weather, but they don't know the price
the wine.
So it's important to build a model that
does well at predicting data it's never seen
before.
The data that we use to build a model
is often called the training data,
and the new data is often called the test
data.
The accuracy of the model on the test data
is often referred to as out-of-sample accuracy.
Let's see how well our model performs
on some test data in R.
We have two data points that we did not use
to build our model
in the file "wine_test.csv".
Let's load this new data file into R.
We'll call it wineTest,
and we'll use the read.csv function to read
in the data
file "wine_test.csv".
If we take a look at the structure of wineTest,
we can see
that we have two observations of the same
variables we had before.
These data points are for the years 1979
and 1980.
To make predictions for these two test points,
we'll use the function predict.
We'll call our predictions predictTest,
and we'll use the predict function.
The first argument to this function is
the name of our model.
Here the name of our model is model4.
Then, we say newdata equals
name of the data set that we want to
make predictions for, in this case wineTest.
If we look at the values in predictTest,
we can see that for the first data point we
predict 6.768925, and for the
second data point we predict 6.684910.
If we look at our structure output,
we can see that the actual Price for the first
data point
is 6.95, and the actual Price for the second
is 6.5.
So it looks like our predictions are pretty
good.
Let's verify this by computing the
R-squared value
for our test set.
Recall that the formula for R-squared
is: R-squared equals
1 minus the Sum of Squared Errors divided
by the Total Sum of Squares.
So let's start by computing the
Sum of Squared Errors
on our test set.
The Sum of Squared Errors equals the
sum of the actual values wineTest
dollar sign Price minus our
predictions predictTest squared,
and then summed.
The Total Sum of Squares equals,
the sum again of the actual
values wineTest$price,
and difference between the mean of the
prices on the training set which is our
baseline model.
We square these values and add them up.
To compute the R-squared now, we type 1 minus
Sum of Squared Errors divided by the
Total Sum of Squares.
And we see that the
out-of-sample R-squared on this test set
is .7944278.
This is a pretty good out-of-sample R-squared.
But while we do well on these two test points,
keep in mind that our test set is really small.
We should increase the size of our test set
to be more confident about the out-of-sample
accuracy
of our model.
We can compute the test set R-squared
for several different models.
This shows the model R-squared
and the test set R-squared for our
model
as we add more variables.
We saw that the model R-squared will always
increases or stays the same
as we add more variables.
However, this is not true for the test set.
We want to look for a model with a
good model R-squared
but also with a good test set R-squared.
In this case we would need
more data
to be conclusive since two data points in
the test set
are not really enough to reach any conclusions.
However, it looks like our model that
uses Average Growing Season Temperature,
Harvest Rain, Age, and Winter Rain does
very well in sample on the training set
as well as out-of-sample on the test set.
Note here that the test set
R-squared can actually be negative.
The model R-squared is never negative
since our model can't do worse on the training
data than the baseline model.
However, our model can do worse on the test
data then the baseline model does.
This leads to a negative R-squared value.
But it looks like our model Average Growing Season Temperature, Harvest Rain, Age, and Winter Rain
beats the baseline model.
We'll see in the next video how well Ashenfelter
did using this model to make predictions.